jacky est ce que tu t'es déjà confessé
oui d'antan au bout et bien sûr il ya
longtemps mais plusieurs fois parce que
d'abord j'ai été élevé chez les soeurs
et j'ai fait ma communion privée la
commune air solennel et puis enfin je
m'entends dire que chez les soeurs on
n'arrêtait pas de ce qu'on faisait
j'étais à l'église du matin au soir
et tu veux prendre l'autobus ça c'est
une histoire terrible j'ai de lire
jusqu'à maintenant j'aurais peut-être
été favorable mais je viens d'avoir un
cas dans dans mes relations d'une dame
qui était complètement complètement mais
c'était fini c'était à légumes s'étaient
plus rien elle ne réagissait plus de
pour un peu on allait arrêter delà de la
soigner
il va savoir ce qui s'est passé d'un
seul coup cette femme est revenue à la
vie elle est réelle elle est partie hier
midi elle était alors la latitude tu
réfléchis quand même tous le disent que
j'ai eu tort est ce que j'aurai tort est
ce que ça là tu réfléchis vraiment à
part comparé tu fais vraiment la peine
de mort
à oui ah oui les hommes qui ont le loup
les femmes qui ont la la la
l'audace le la cruauté de martyriser des
enfants de les tuer les de martyriser
des vieillards de les de les tuer alors
là oui tout de suite tout une meilleure
je discuterai même pas il n'y aurait
même pas de gros serrières tout de suite
oui est ce que tu crois en dieu oui et
je suis obligé de parents dieu parce
qu'il est un gosse à 16 ans j'ai eu un
très grave at six ans je suis tombé de 7
étages par la fenêtre et je suis là s'il
n'y avait pas eu de mon dieu je crois
que tu me verrez certainement pas
croyable non non je pense pas mais je
pense que les gens qui sont très
méchants très enfin ça j'espère penser à
ça sont punis dans la vie oui mais un
juste retour des choses sales on retombe
sur le nez sais pas si c'est le diable
autre chose mais oui je veux croire à ça
si je devais partir là
et tu ton fils michel à côté de toi et
tu es un seul mot à lui dit ah tu dirais
quoi si je vais mourir
il dirait je t'aime je t'aime je ça a
été toute ma vie ras jédir esm et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de linda hardy
tube abonnez vous il m'était impossible
ou